nous retrouvons le docteur car vice
président de l'association des médecins
microbiologiste-infectiologue du québec
dr weiss bonsoir
alors quand vous regardez les données
d'aujourd'hui et l'accumulation des
données depuis 14 jours
qu'est ce que ça vous dit sur l'endroit
où nous sommes actuellement on se situe
on est dans une phase d'augmentation et
d'accélération de la cour parce que vous
apercevez de wes qu'on était il ya une
semaine et où est-ce qu'on était il ya
deux semaines il faut dire aussi qu'on a
rattrapé un certain nombre de tests donc
il ya beaucoup de résultats qui sont
sorties ces derniers temps et on pourra
discuter de la façon dont on conteste au
québec où est-ce qu'on se situe sur la
planète
donc il ya je dirais une accélération du
nombre de cas on s'aperçoit que la
majorité des cas sont quand même sur
l'île de montréal et qu'il ya certains
secteurs de l'île de maria qui sont plus
affectées que d'autres mais d'un autre
côté c'est tout le terrain qui est
affecté par ce qu'on voit des cas
partout au québec dont on peut pas dire
moi je vis dans telle région c'est pas
trop grave je peux me prémunir yapaka ou
très peu de cas des rations est ce qu'on
à entrevoir le pays classe qu'on
entrevoit ne sommet ou pas encore on est
loin du sommet si on se fie aux autres
la question ça va être le sommet on en
est on sera probablement d'ici trois
semaines
on va atteindre une phase plateau la
question c'est de savoir jusqu'à combien
on va être capable d'écraser une courbe
pour essayer d'avoir un plateau qui est
le moins élevé possible quand on compare
les cas au québec et ailleurs au canada
on va voir la carte du canada vous vous
dites que c'est parce que on a testé au
québec entre autres davantage les
personnes qui étaient à risque
c'est pour ça qu'on a davantage de
résultats positifs où il ya plus de cas
tout simplement au québec aussi il ya
peut-être une combinaison des deux mais
c'est définitivement côté vrai qu'on a
testé beaucoup plus que l'ontario
si on se compare à l'ontario est une
province peut-être plus similaires oui
on a testé beaucoup plus à londres que
comparé à notariat l'ontario par capita
on a augmenté notre capacité à faire des
tests
il ya eu énormément de travail qui a été
fait sur
la capacité à développer ces tests là
vous savez on peut se comparer par
exemple on dit qu'en allemagne se fait à
peu près 500 mille tests par semaine
donc vous comparer au québec que si on
arrivait à faire
l'esc ce qu'on avait prévu d'environ
6000 test par semaine
alors on sera vendue autour d'à peu près
car à 6016 par jour par jour dans
quarante mille tests au québec on est à
peu près 10% de la population allemande
donc on serait dans ce qui est
probablement le pays qui a la meilleure
capacité de tests sur la planète
actuellement bon donc de ce qu'on verra
si on arrivé à ce niveau là il ya des
petites différences avec l'allemagne on
pourra en reparler bruit sur le nom d'
parce que le nerf de la guerre c'est le
nombre de personnes qui doivent se
rendre dans les hôpitaux chez vous et
ailleurs au québec au canada sans ses
hospitalisations au québec comment vous
jugez le taux d'hospitalisation
jusqu'ici à écouter on avait dit
regarder si vous faites un chiffre
stable qui a à peu près 1600 cas il ya
environ 106 hospitalisation c'est un
petit peu moins que ce qu'on prévoyait
mais il faut dire que les chiffres
valent ce qu'ils valent
on essaie aussi de j'essaie de ne pas
garder les gens à l'hôpital lorsqu'on
n'a pas besoin de les garder et on est
aussi capable de vous dire hey regardez
les gens qui s'en vont avec soins
intensifs donc si on regarde la
proportion elle est aussi un peu dans ce
qu'on s'attendait la seule chose que je
vous dirais la tendance puis pour voir
ça de façon réelle tous les jours en
traitant des patients c'est que c'est
des patients qui malheureusement ont
besoin de rester plus longtemps à
l'hôpital parce que leur besoin
d'oxygène et demandant donc c'est des
gens qu'on doit regarder relativement
longtemps pour des patients de cette
catégorie n'a je m'explique
souvent c'est des patients pas tous mais
ça peut être des patients qui sont quand
même relativement en bonne forme
si et qui ne sont utilisés que pour
cette condition là est normalement des
patients comme ça que fring de menie
puis j'en ai vu des milliers dans ma vie
au bout de trois quatre jours on les
renvoie à la maison c'est pas charland
la tendance à les garder un petit peu
plus longtemps parce que leur demande
d'oxygène est un peu plus élevée et
demandant si vous voulez très bien mais
chavez quelques questions en rafale du
public pourquoi est il plus dit
difficile de fabriquer un vaccin contre
le corps n'avait russe que quand une
grippe saisonnière
est ce parce que la grippe on à la
hausse est depuis très très longtemps
même si c'est un vaccin qui ait ses
limites et ses défauts c'est comme si
vous étiez capable de dire écoutez en
fait un gâteau on connaît déjà le gros
de la recette on peut changer que des
décorations
alors c'est juste que là on part de zéro
et c'est d'eux qu'il faut comprendre que
pour faire un vaccin ce que ça en il
faut trouver une partie du virus qui est
tout le temps présente tout le temps
constant il va favoriser la création
d'immunoglobuline d'anticorps et que ces
anticorps là vont être protecteur enfin
c'est pas juste le fait d'avoir des
antilles tort c'est d'avoir des
anticorps qui vont vous protéger contre
une réflexion par le virus
donc il faut trouver cette clé là est
justement la deuxième question les
personnes guéries du camp n'avait russe
parce qu'il ya beaucoup ont développé
des anticorps une transfusion sanguine
serait telle efficace pour créer un
médicament alors c'est une excellente
question ça s'appelle la sérothérapie
c'est déjà très vieux il ya des gens qui
ont fait ça par les années 50
et il ya des gens qui ont tenté ça même
en chine il ya même je vous dirai dans
beaucoup de pays mais mon canada des
gens qui commencent à y penser c'est à
dire on prend les gens qui ont guéri en
france qu'on appelle un sérum
convalescents dont ils ont guéri et on
s'est dit si ils ont guéri c'est qu'ils
ont développé une bonne réponse
immunitaire
donc il devrait avoir des anticorps des
immunoglobulines dans leur sens et si on
l'administré à des gens malades
ça pourrait les aider à mieux se
défendre en d'autres mots c'est comme si
vous recrutiez une armée qui est déjà
aguerris pour venir aider combattre
l'infection très bien je pense dans la
question 5 une personne atteinte de la
commune est fait quand tu as juste
combien de jours avant bon c'est la
fameuse question qui revient toujours
pas ce que on a l'impression que la
science a bougé là-dessus contenu des
études chinoises alors la science va
toujours bouclée là-dessus ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est en sciences la seule façon
de ne pas se tromper c'est de pas faire
de la science donc il est clair qu'on à
fond sur ce numéro de cela c'est on
apprend de plus en plus et donc ce qu'on
s'aperçoit quand même c'est que les gens
sont malades sont symptomatiques sont
beaucoup plus contagieux
il ya probablement des gens qui sont
plus symptomatique ou pas symptomatique
et qui vont excrété le virus pendant les
jours précédant le début
symptôme faut pas oublier non plus qu'il
ya des gens qui sont tellement peu
symptomatiques qui pour eux ils sont pas
malades
alors c'est pour ça des fois un moment
donné là la définition de la
symptomatique
alors pour l'instant ne pas être un cas
symptomatique veut dire que vous êtes
probablement et je vais probablement
souligné pas un transmetteur du virus
mais oui ça peut appeler ça peut être
appelé à changer selon ce que la
littérature très bien quel rôle joue le
numéro 6 la température dans tout ça on
a beaucoup de questions les gens
notamment parce que vous savez monsieur
trempe avait dit quand il va faire chaud
ça va ça va faire disparaître le virus
est ce que la température le temps comme
il l'est la chaleur peut influencer la
pandémie l'épidémie oui en général
lorsque la température devient plus
chaude les coronavirus moa san antonio
pourrait avoir un effet oui sur
l'environnement mais par contre faut pas
oublier que la majorité des gens qui se
contaminent il se contaminent par
rapport à des gens qui sont très proches
d'eux alors ça c'était peut-être plus
vrai quand tout le monde était dehors
mais l'avait tout le confort on a les
gens devraient vouloir priver ce compte
ils ont moins de contraintes avec
d'autres dr vince une petite dernière 15
secondes il ya eu un peu de confusion
mais si vous êtes en quarantaine la si
vous êtes en isolement obligatoire
maintenant vous revenez de l'étranger
mais vous avez zéro symptômes aller
prendre une marche d'or à deux mètres de
thé autour de vous comme un isoloir
savalas vous pouvez le prescrire comme
médecin la wii écoutez il faut avoir du
gros bon sens voilà alors ça veut dire
si vous allez tous dehors vous êtes
avait personne vous êtes seul vous êtes
avec quelqu'un qui est dans la même
situation qu vous qui revenue avec vous
vous êtes en quarantaine vous évitez
tous les contacts avec les autres vous
ne vous approchez pas surtout vous
n'êtes pas malade donc plus fort a
souligné qu'il faut soyez
asymptomatiques
si vous toussez cracher match et cetera
c'est pas le moment d'aller marcher
dehors il faut écouter notre voix
intérieure le gros bon sens aussi la
photo perte de soi de vue on peut pas
réglementer tout réglementer le moindre
détail
dr weiss toujours en plaisir merci
beaucoup
portez vous bien faites attention à vous
on a besoin d'eux
merci et bonne soirée à voir